did you guys grow up with money like
your dad was
kardashian the lawyer robert robert
kardashian who died of cancer right
mm-hmm
um very famous attorney represented o.j
and all that stuff
your dad was a well-off guy right yeah
we i mean we grew up in beverly hills we
definitely had a really privile
privileged life but my dad was extremely
strict we
all had to you know get jobs we knew at
18. we had to be out of the house we had
to pay for everything out of the house
at 18. was it traumatic was
it traumatic for you when we did let me
take you back a bunch of years when your
dad was alive
your mom was good friends with nicole
oj's wife yes
and the week before nicole was murdered
you guys actually went away on a
vacation with her right
yeah every uh spring break we would go
to cabo san lucas mexico so
and nicole was beautiful and a nice
person right yeah incredibly sweet
right i was actually best friends with
sydney simpson her their daughter
are you still in touch with sydney no i
feel like she like kind of dropped off
like this blew her mind so bad that i
feel like she's like gone somewhere i
mean i don't know where she lives i
think she's doing really well i think
she moved and went to college i think in
boston um we speak to her brothers her
two brothers
do you write her does anyone in touch
with her from like friends from the past
no not really and what was that like i
mean
here you were good friends with nicole
and i guess you knew o.j
killed her and then your dad had to
represent o.j
i think at the time like i just believed
we were me and my sister courtney chloe
was a little bit younger but courtney
and i just believed
everything that my dad would do we were
such daddy's girls because we felt like
you know my mom had remarried so fast
and it kind of broke my dad's heart and
she moved on so we just sided with my
dad no matter what it was
right so at the beginning my dad
definitely did believe in oj did
couldn't believe that his best friend
would do that um
do you think he really believed that he
was innocent yeah for a long time
right and then um so we always were at
my dad's house and there was you know
bob shapiro and johnny cochran and
they're having all these meetings and
we'd go there
you would go to the meetings and o.j
would be where he was at my dad's house
so everyone was like the bronco chase
happened from my dad's house like all
that stuff like it was we were very much
in the heart of it all
was o.j at your house a lot even like
planning his defense or was he in jail
he was in custody right they didn't
release him right okay so where he was
he was staying at our house and we'd go
to my mom's house
where faye resnick was living and she
was really close to the brown family so
we'd hear one thing and
you know it was very divided and then
going to my dad's house and it was all
pro oj and we're like wait what do we
believe and so
right because your mom's probably
sitting there going that's my best
friend and o.j killed
my best friend and now my ex-husband's
defending him and and you guys are
caught in the middle in a sense during
this whole thing saying gee who's right
he's telling the truth i know for us as
kids it was very hard like like for me
personally i just felt like
if i was at my mom's i couldn't really
talk about my dad if i was at my
dad's i couldn't talk about my mom now
like after the oj trial was done they
became
best friends and my mom and my my dad
and my stepdad played golf together and
it was fine but during the trial it was
awful for us kids so when o.j was found
innocent your dad was happy and your mom
was miserable
i think at the end like if you notice
like i your dad kind of removed himself
afterwards
he shocked yeah when they read the
verdict we were all just kind of okay
looks shocked
no one was more shocked than o.j believe
me after the trial your dad and o.j
had a falling out right i think so he
kind of kept it away from us
i mean that was like uncle oj and we'd
see him all the time so after that
i remember the day he got out of jail i
went to his house with my dad
and you know said hi to him and after
that i don't think we saw him again i
think they had a falling out
you